hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2007 british fictional heist crime movie
called flawless
the movie begins with a young journalist
named cassie j who arrives at a
restaurant to interview laura quinn
ex-employee of london diamond
corporation about her achievement of
being the first female manager in a
male-dominated environment before she
begins her story she takes out a very
rare huge diamond which she stole from
the company
the scene moves to 1960 when the young
laura goes to the office and it is shown
that the company's size is dominated by
men
meanwhile people of london are
protesting to the company's director
milton and his son ollie because
hundreds of workers have died because of
diamonds
upon their arrival they gather the
company's officials to discuss the
massacre the young laura attempts to
speak up giving several suggestions to
resolve the chaos but it seems like
milton doesn't take her opinion
seriously
before milton dismisses the officials he
announces that peter boland will be the
newest managing director of the company
laura is disappointed because she is the
most hardworking employee in the company
and the boss chose boland over her
despite losing her opportunity to become
the first female managing director ever
laura doesn't give up and writes her
motivation in a small note
she then comes across a woman who
invites her to have lunch together but
laura politely rejects the invitation
and chooses to continue working until
late night instead
while focusing on her work she is
approached by a janitor named hobbs who
is amazed with her dedication to the
company
she always goes home late and continues
working at home
the next day laura proposes a strategy
to milton suggesting the london diamond
corporation secretly extend their
contract with russian to maintain their
relationship and also because they buy
diamonds at a magnificent price
it seems like milton and other
colleagues agree with the solution
just after she leaves milton's room she
meets harold reynolds an old friend who
admires laura's cleverness and offers
her to work at his company allied
banking
he tells laura to consider the offer and
gives her his name card
after that she walks to his office and
accidentally finds a movie ticket in the
envelope
she goes to the cinema and turns out it
was hobbs who put the ticket laura
suddenly panics but hobbs makes it clear
that he is a happily married man
they both sit and laura is uncomfortable
with him as the janitor always reads her
private correspondence he also claims
that he has been observing her for a
while stating how she has been passed
over in the last three years for someone
who was less qualified than her laura
becomes terrified and almost walks away
but hobbs finally tells her that she is
going to be fired because of her russian
proposal
however she does not believe him
still unsure about what hobbs just said
laura goes to the secretary's room and
lies to the secretary
as she runs to the lobby in panic laura
searches the room and finds her
termination letter
the frustrated laura accidentally finds
harold's name card and immediately
arranges a meeting with him
unfortunately he cannot offer her a
position as there's a conflict of
interest and he also heard from the
company that laura is incompetent in the
evening laura is worried about her
career and even dreams about her being
arrested for trying to steal diamonds
she then meets hobbs at greyhound racing
competition where the janitor reveals
his plan to steal diamonds from the
company to avenge his deceased wife
he brings her to his place where he
explains the details of the heist plan
to laura
he is confident that the plan will work
as he has been working there for 16
years
he intends to go for the vault while he
is mopping because during that time he
works mostly unattended
laura warns him as the vaults codes are
changed weekly and only entrusted to two
people in the company eaton and milton
hobbs knows that milton keeps the code
under his desk but recently he can't
find it under the office desk anymore
because of that he asks for laura's help
to sneak into milton's place and find
the code for him
before laura leaves hobbs tells her that
he will keep the stolen diamonds in a
thermos
as planned laura attends the party at
milton's house
after dancing with the russians
representative she goes upstairs and
sneaks into milton's room however she
can't find any codes under the drawer
suddenly milton comes into the room and
opens a safe there
meanwhile laura secretly observes from a
distance
after the boss leaves she manages to
open the safe and finds the code she's
looking for the following day laura
hands over the code to the janitor and
demands to know every detail of the plan
while heading to her room she is shocked
when she sees surveillance cameras are
being installed at the office
she immediately informs hobbs about the
cameras and where they are placed and
suggest they call off the heist
laura eventually finds another way to
get into the vault
she reveals that even though there are
eight cameras in the basement only four
cameras are active at one time
since the images cycle in 15 second
intervals meaning that each image is off
screen for 60 seconds
laura doubts hobbs can finish the job
but he is optimistic that one minute is
enough for him to sneak into the vault
and escape undetected
they then synchronize their watches and
agree to proceed with the plan the next
evening the pair arrive at the office
and execute the plan
hobbs goes to the security room and
begins the countdown after the images
are switching each step of the plan is
done precisely until hobbs eventually
arrives at the vault and tries to open
it however he is a bit late in the image
switches showing hobbs trying to break
the vault
fortunately laura calls the security
room and distracts the guard just before
he spots hobbs
inside the vault hobbs is seen taking
the diamonds with his thermos and
escapes from the vault undetected in the
morning the janitor leaves the building
with the bottle but suddenly gets called
to fix the clogged toilet a few moments
later eaton opens the vault and shocks
the entire office including laura when
he informs them that two tons of
diamonds in the vault are gone
meanwhile hobbs goes home and pours all
the liquid inside the thermos but there
are no diamonds at all
back at the building milton tells the
senior staff that they will handle the
matter privately and immediately hires
finch to investigate the case
laura secretly confronts hobbs and
demands an explanation as he told her
that he's only going to steal diamonds
that fit in the thermos
he tells her to remain calm and keep to
her routine as they discussed
laura returns to the office and goes to
milton's room where all the company's
senior staff gather
mr boyle a lawyer sent anonymously
explains his client's demand and then
gives milton a small box that contains
one of the stolen diamonds to prove that
the diamonds are in the steelers
possession
not long after finch interrogates laura
to find the potential perpetrator and
their motive
before he leaves the room finch asks
laura about hobbs because he saw her
meeting hobbs in the corridor earlier
afterwards laura requests to be given
authority to liaise with finch on the
investigation
on their way to the vault
finch discovers the new security system
and states that the surveillance cameras
are actually not very secure
at the basement everyone is breaking the
wall to find a hole because finch
believes that the perpetrator must have
penetrated it somewhere to get the
diamonds out on the other hand clifton
sinclair representative from the
company's underwriters kings row gives 5
million pounds to restore diamond
inventories to an acceptable level
however milton states that that amount
of money is not enough as they are the
sole supplier of diamonds to six
continents
finch shows up and concludes that the
crime was committed by the company's
employee who obtained the vaults code
from the milton's residence during the
party
laura then meets hobbs in the sewer and
tells him that no one will buy that
amount of diamonds since london diamonds
are the sole buyer
she adds that demanding a ransom is
useless as they won't pay
he still refuses to reveal the location
of the diamonds thus laura leaves and
will try to find the diamond while at
her room finch appears and asks for
laura's fingerprints he asks for laura's
assistance in an interrogation which she
agrees to
they both then go to a room where hobbs
has been waiting
finch interrogates hobbs who manages to
answer all the questions smoothly when
finch is away laura realizes that she
might have left a fingerprint and
suggests they negotiate with milton and
sinclair
however hobbs is still confident that
they will pay or they will never find
the diamonds again
still that evening finch examines
laura's fingerprints and he also figures
out laura and hobbes's meeting in the
greyhound race
meanwhile the frustrated sinclair
contacts a news media company and plans
to reveal the heist to the public
milton orders his men to convene a
meeting with all syndicate members
forcing them to pay him or he will crush
them
soon after he is informed that the press
are waiting outside
milton falls down and suddenly dies due
to a heart attack
on the other side finch confronts laura
to discuss her fingerprints found in
milton's place in the meeting with
hobbes
he then accuses her of being the
perpetrator of the heist
unfortunately a man suddenly rushes in
informing finch about milton's death
after finch goes laura immediately goes
to the restroom due to a panic attack
and eventually realizes that hobbs might
transfer all the diamonds through pipes
she descends to the sewer and
coincidentally meets the janitor there
laura threatens him that she will tell
everything to the authorities and tries
to run away but falls off
milton tells her that his real motive
for the heist is to avenge his dead wife
his wife had an excellent chance to be
fully cured from cancer but the
insurance company led by sinclair were
not willing to help him at that time
he finally reveals that he repeatedly
put all the diamonds in the garbage bags
and then unloaded all of them through
the sink
surprisingly a huge rare diamond was
stuck in the closet so he decided to
send it to milton as a proof
back at sinclair the syndicates find out
about his intention to reveal the case
to the public there he makes it clear
that they will never get the money back
and then returns to his room
realizing that his life is over he grabs
a gun and kills himself
after the demanded money is transferred
to a bank account the lawyer receives a
call from hobbs telling him he sent
another gift to him
after telling the story hobbs withdraws
his intention to shoot laura and leaves
her alone
laura explores deeper into the sewer and
eventually finds the stolen diamonds
she informs the company's senior staff
and authorities about her findings and
they immediately retrieve the diamonds
finch approaches laura and confesses
that they have never found her prince in
milton's safe but on the opera glasses
in his office instead
turns out that laura also uses this
opportunity to keep a huge diamond for
herself
since then ali takes over the company
and shows the journalist that the
diamonds were never lost
it's also determined that hobbs acted
alone in the heist
at the end of the movie the elder laura
tells the journalist that hobbs was
never found and she accidentally
received 100 million pounds from an
anonymous man
before she leaves she gives cassie her
diary book
cassie figures out that laura spent all
the money for helping others
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching